Dean Devlin the original writer of the
1994 Stargate movie has been talking
about where he would have gone with
parts two and three of the trilogy him
and Roland Emerick wanted to make
thank God it didn't happen
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
move your Channel
[Music]
so it's fair to say the actual premise
of Stargate is a little silly basically
the idea for the first movie in the
question that is answered in the first
movie was
did aliens build the pyramids now a lot
of ancient astronaut theorists have said
this for a long time that the pyramids
are just beyond our capability to have
built five thousand years ago or perhaps
they're much much older than even that
so perhaps they were built by aliens now
I'm not saying it was aliens but it was
probably aliens so it's fair to say that
the original movie was based in an
extraordinary premise now the SG-1
series Atlantis and SGU to a much lesser
extent did explore the mythologies and
the mysteries of our planet they
explored lots and lots of these you know
they did explore the Egyptian myths and
um all of the different gods Etc I mean
at the end of the day all the gold
walled were the ancient gods the idea is
that these gold were really those gods
and those stories just became mythology
now that in itself is a slightly
extraordinary borderline silly premise
for a TV show but it was done so well
and so subtly that we just loved it
but what was going to happen in part two
and three well the big question for part
two of the trilogy the dean devil
enrolled Emerick planned was why are
there pyramids in the Mayan culture so
that film would have been I imagined
quite similar actually in lots of ways
to sg1 but instead of you know an
Egyptian god in ra it would have been a
Mayan God and it would have tied in a
lot of the mythology from the Mayan
myths I do wonder if somehow they'd have
tied in the 2012 myth the story where
the Mayan calendar ends in 2012 and
there was a big belief that actually
that was going to Mark the end of the
world I wonder if Roland emmerich ever
did a movie that explored that
oh yeah he did
so that would have been a big
possibility for whatever Direction
they'd have took that movie
it's the third movie that I'm a little
bit more is that going too far about
so in the third movie they were gonna
try to bring all of these different
things together and the two examples
that Dean devil him brought up in an
interview recently was that the yeti
would have been in it and so would have
the Loch Ness Monster
and that the movie idea was to bring all
of these extraordinary myths and stories
from around the world and to get them to
make sense
now I'm in two minds about that
in one hand Stargate was always about
the extraordinary if you actually break
down a lot of components of the series
and think about it logically
it's kind of stupid
but it was done so brilliantly that you
know we didn't care on the other hand
the Loch Ness Monster
and the yeti
they were going to bring both of these
things in to the movie and probably an
awful lot more
I don't see
in my wildest dreams how that would have
worked and I can't help but think thank
God it didn't now in 2015 there was a
plan for Dean Devlin and Roman Emrick to
come back
and potentially actually make these
movies
now that didn't happen
but could it in the future
well I get asked this a lot because you
know I don't know if you've noticed but
on this channel we talk about Stargate
quite a lot I've been very very lucky to
actually have an insight into what's
going on at MGM and Amazon and to find
out exclusively and first a lot of the
information about the Stargate Revival
now we're very very close to actually
that getting finally officially
announced but what is going to be
announced
well
again Rick a few months ago actually
said that they've been conversations
with MGM again because if they do a
movie they would have to bring Roland
Emery back in he's actually contracted
with MGM that if they do a cinematic
release of a movie he should be involved
now he can decline to be involved but
that's the current standing
now he said he's not particularly
interested in that project because it
seems that the TV audience what is
important now that filled us with joy
because if Roland emerick's involved I'm
a little concerned because he's not
exactly doing great movies since
Stargate he's done you know there's a
couple of highs in there but an awful
lot of lows
so I don't want him from any creative
control within a new Stargate movie but
it sounds like he doesn't really want
that creative control because he's not
going to be allowed to do the original
movie trilogy that he wants to do
because the TV audience in what matter
the audience of sg1 SGA and SGU so
Amazon have enough sense not to annoy
your skaters and not to do a hard reboot
of the series
now I talking to people at MGM and um
you know in and around the industry I'm
very confident that there's not the plan
the plan is to do a continuation now
anybody that thinks that means that
Canon won't be affected
is going to get disappointed like
anything where there's a nearly 20-year
gap between a show ending and a new show
starting there are going to be
differences there's going to be a new
team creating the Stargate series
they're going to want to inject some of
their own ideas into it that is just the
reality of making TV and making movies
and as I've told you repeatedly the plan
does seem to be to do a cinematic movie
of Stargate first and to follow on with
a larger franchise
that cinematic movie though will be a
continuation of the sg1 SGA and SGU
storylines yes there will be differences
but on the whole
it's going to be a proper continuation
there will not be a reboot in sight
so all we can say is thank God Dean
Devlin and ronaldomrick did not get to
make their Trilogy we wouldn't have got
sg1 when we did and I think it's fair to
say that for most Gators we love the
movie
but it's sg1 that's in our hearts and
it's sg1 that matters
so
doing Devlin thank you for your
contribution to the Stargate world you
wrote a brilliant movie that then Brad
Wright Robert Cooper developed into an
even better series but as Roland Emerick
says it's the TV audience that matter so
thank you
but no thank you we don't want the
trilogy we want a continuation of sg1
but guys get into the comments to tell
me what you think about some of these
ideas Dean devil has been talking about
do you think it is maybe a little bit of
a disappointment we didn't get the
trilogy that then maybe would have
turned into a TV series or actually is
it perfect the way it went and you know
what we came that close in 2015 to
getting this trilogy
maybe it's a good thing that we didn't
but guys get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos you can also go to
sidestrek.com where there's brilliant
merchandise like this and you can
actually pick your sg1 team
um you get it on a monkey get on a
t-shirt you can get on a hat
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you can see most
of our new videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see it
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time